partout au Québec la même photo
électorale mais ici c'est d'abord celle
de la candidate locale alors comment va
citer la quatrième fois que Dominique
Anglade se rend à son local électoral
depuis le début de la campagne oui
bonjour madame Dufour c'est Dominique
Anglade du Parti libéral du Québec
l'objectif en cette journée de vote par
anticipation mobiliser les électeurs
pour assurer sa réélection vous pouvez
voter d'avance plutôt que de voter le
jour même de l'élection mais celle qui a
déjà été élue deux fois député de Saint
Henri Sainte-Anne porte maintenant un
nouveau titre chef du Parti libéral du
Québec on est capable de porter puis de
comprendre ce qui se passe sur le
terrain ici puis de le porter un autre
niveau pour tous les Québécois et donc
ça fait une voix encore plus forte pour
ses Henri 50 dans les enjeux qui disons
bonjour c'est Nicolas votre candidat de
la CAQ c'est sûr que d'être candidat
contre la chef d'un parti il y a une
excitation de plus le candidat kakis
croit de son côté que le nouveau statut
de son adversaire libéral pour elle lui
être profitable parce que les gens me
disent ceux qui ont eu des ministres qui
ont eu des chefs de parties
donc ils veulent quelqu'un qui va être
localement
oui bonjour je m'appelle Guillaume je
suis votre candidat pour Québec
solidaire ça va bien c'est pas une
question d'être pour ou contre quelqu'un
c'est une question de quelle partie
démocratiquement va représenter le plus
les intérêts de santé pour le candidat
solidaire la volonté n'est pas de
défaire la chef libéral mais plutôt
d'offrir les solutions de son parti au
problème de la circonscription la
circonscription le possède de personnes
elle est pas celle de moi elle est pas
celle de Madame Morgan elle possède la
CAC c'est une circonscription électorale
comme une autre la circonscription de
Saint Henri Sainte-Anne existe depuis
1992 et a toujours été libéral en 2018
Dominique Anglade l'avait emporté par
plus de 4000 voix devant Québec
solidaire
si certains espèrent que la tendance du
vote se maintiennent
exactement
pensez madame Anglade puis on trouve ça
dommage parce qu'on respecte on aime
cette personne mais les idées de Québec
solidaires c'est les notes
pourquoi la GAC parce que c'est des
choses qui étaient bonnes pour nous
autres j'ai décidé d'appuyer le Parti
québécois j'ai quand même eu peur à me
donner que le PQ disparaisse puis que je
trouvais qu'il y avait un bon
chefs
ont besoin de brasser la cage est-ce que
vous gardez le moral quand même le moral
de la députée sortante lui semble
intacte moi je gagne un service
confiance aussi que c'est d'abord ici
que son avenir politique ce jour à lundi
ici Mathieu papillon Radio-Canada
Montréal